But they must be pissed.
The weed's legal everywhere else because people used to go to Holland,
specifically friends that own coffee shops over there and they're like,
yeah,
there's,
there's a lot of fucking,
well,
what's going on right now is there's,
um,
if I understood what he was telling me,
right?
Um,
Canada is investing shit,
tons of money with the government over there to like corporate,
like stark growing corporate we'd like,
and they're going to phase out to the locals and take it over.
Ah,
like during the phase out the coffee shop,
because their weed isn't legal in Holland,
it's decriminalized.
If you own a weed shop,
you can only have,
let's say 500 grams at a time in the shop legally.
All right?
If you have a good shop,
you're moving that,
you know,
in a fucking afternoon.
So,
and getting,
bringing weed to your shop is illegal.
Like,
it's like it's a smuggling operation has to be in there and once it's in there,
it's okay.
Once it's in there,
you could sell it,
but getting it to your spot as the problem,
it's fucking illegal to move that much weed.
It's fucked up.
Like these guys.
I have no,
a couple of guys,
I want a cup of coffee shops and they're just like,
it's fuckery,
man.
You and getting it,
it's like us constant.
It's like half a criminal operation.
They're running and it used to be that you get mushrooms,
you should be able to get mushrooms,
you to be able to get like a bunch of shit.
And now you can't hard like narcotics,
like coke or anything like that.
But anything natural,
like mushrooms,
you could get acid when I was first in there,
but I don't know if that was legal because I was really young.
I just,
well Holland,
just a wild ass place.